nos persiga,
intentando decapitarnos con todo su ser.
He estado ahí y les aseguro que no es nada agradable.
Traigo algunos videos para mostrarles
lo qué es usar las Google Glass bajo el casco,
y darles una idea de eso.
Desafortunadamente, no son imágenes de las prácticas de la NFL,
porque la idea de la NFL de tecnología emergente
es un submarino subiendo a la superficie.
Pero —(risas)—, hacemos lo que podemos.
Así que veamos un vídeo.
(Video) Chris Kluwe: Vamos.
Es horrible ser tacleado.
Un momento. Acerquémonos un poco.
¿Preparados?
¡Vamos!
Chris Kluwe: Como pueden ver,
es una probadita de lo que es ser tacleado
en el campo de fútbol,
desde la perspectiva del tacleado.
Se habrán dado cuenta de que falta gente,
el resto del equipo.
Tenemos un vídeo de ellos, cortesía de la Universidad de Washington.
(Vídeo) Mariscal de campo: ¡Ratones 54! ¡Ratones 54!
¡Azul 8, Azul 8! ¡Vamos!
Chris Kluwe: Esto los acerca un poco más
a la sensación estar en el campo,
pero no tiene nada que ver
con estar en la NFL.
Los fans quieren esa experiencia.
Los fans quieren estar en el campo, ser sus jugadores favoritos,
y me han preguntado en YouTube y en Twitter:
"¿Se puede ver desde el ángulo de un mariscal de campo
o de un corredor?
Queremos experimentar eso".
Una vez que tenemos esa experiencia con GoPro y Google Glass,
¿cómo nos metemos de lleno?, ¿cómo lo llevamos al siguiente nivel?
Lo llevamos a ese nivel usando algo llamado Oculus Rift,
que seguramente muchos ya conocen.
El Oculus Rift ha sido descrito como
el aparato de realidad virtual más realista jamás creado,
y no es palabrería barata.
Y voy a enseñarles el porqué, con este vídeo.
(Vídeo) Hombre: ¡Oh, oh!
¡No, no, no! ¡No quiero seguir jugando! ¡No!
¡Oh, Dios mío! ¡Ah!
CK: Esa es la experiencia de un hombre en una montaña rusa
temiendo por su vida.
¿Cuál será la experiencia de un fan
cuando grabemos un vídeo de Adrian Peterson cruzando la línea,
deshaciéndose de un tacleador con el brazo
antes de correr y hacer una anotación?
¿Cuál será la experiencia de un fan
cuando pueda ser Messi corriendo por la cancha,
lanzando el balón al fondo de la red?
¿O Federer haciendo un saque en Wimbledon?
¿Cuál será su experiencia
cuando descienda de una montaña a más de 100 km/h
como un esquiador olímpico?
Tal vez se incrementen la ventas de pañales para adultos.
(Risas)
Pero esto no es aún realidad aumentada,
es solo realidad virtual, R.V.
¿Cómo alcanzamos la realidad aumentada, R.A.?
Alcanzaremos la realidad aumentada
cuando los entrenadores, los mánagers y los dueños
vean la información de lo que la gente quiere ver y piensen:
"¿Cómo usamos esto para mejorar nuestros equipos?
¿Cómo lo usamos para ganar partidos?"
Porque ellos siempre usan la tecnología para ganar.
Les gusta ganar. Les da dinero.
Así que, he aquí un breve repaso sobre la tecnología en la NFL.
En 1965, los Potros de Baltimore
le pusieron una muñequera a su mariscal de campo
para que jugara más rápido.
Ganaron el Super Bowl ese año.
Otros equipos decidieron imitarlos.
Más gente vio el partido porque fue más emocionante, más rápido.
En 1994, la NFL colocó radios
en los cascos de los mariscales de campo
y después en los de los defensas.
Tuvieron más espectadores porque era más rápido, más entretenido.
En 2023, imaginen que son un jugador volviendo a su grupo
y ven su próxima jugada mostrada
delante de Uds., en un visor de plástico que llevan puesto.
Ya no tendrán que preocuparse por olvidar una jugada.
o por memorizar la estrategia.
Solo salen al campo y reaccionan.
Y los entrenadores lo quieren porque si no se siguen sus instrucciones,
se pierden partidos, y ellos odian perder partidos.
Si pierdes partidos te despiden como entrenador.
Y ellos no quieren eso.
Pero la realidad aumentada no es solo un manual de estrategias mejorado.
La realidad aumentada es también un modo de recopilar información
y usarla en tiempo real para mejorar tu forma de jugar el partido.
¿Cómo se haría?
Bien, una opción muy simple sería tener una cámara
en cada esquina del estadio
teniendo una vista desde lo alto de la gente que está abajo.
También obtienes información
de los sensores de los cascos y los acelerómetros,
algo en lo que ya se está trabajando.
Y toda esa información se la envías a tus jugadores.
Los buenos equipos sabrán enviarla,
los malos tendrán sobrecarga de información.
Esto diferenciaría a los buenos equipos de los malos.
Así, tu equipo de informáticos será tan importante como tus reclutadores,
y el análisis de datos dejará de ser solo para nerds,
será también para deportistas. ¿Quién lo habría imaginado?
¿Cómo sería en el campo?
Imaginen que son el mariscal de campo.
Recibes el balón y retrocedes.
Buscas a un receptor abierto.
De repente, un flash en la parte izquierda de tu visor te avisa
que un defensa detrás de ti va a atacarte.
Normalmente, no lo verías, pero el sistema de R.A te avisa.
Avanzas al área de protección.
Otro flash te avisa que hay un receptor abierto.
Lanzas el balón, pero te derriban
y el balón pierde la trayectoria.
No sabes dónde aterrizará.
Sin embargo, el receptor ve en su visor un área de hierba que se ilumina
y puede modificar la carrera.
Se aproxima, atrapa el balón, corre y anota.
El público enloquece y los fans han seguido la jugada
desde cada ángulo.
Esto es algo que creará una emoción masiva en el partido.
Hará que montones de personas lo vean,
porque la gente quiere vivir esa experiencia.
Los fans quieren estar en el campo,
quieren ser su jugador favorito.
La realidad aumentada será parte del deporte
porque es demasiado rentable para no serlo.
Pero lo que yo les pregunto es:
¿queremos que este sea el único uso de la realidad aumentada?
¿Vamos a utilizarla solo como pan y circo,
como nuestro entretenimiento habitual?
Porque creo que podemos usarla para algo más.
Creo que podemos usar la realidad aumentada
para fomentar la empatía entre los seres humanos,
para mostrar a alguien
cómo es, literalmente, estar en el lugar de otra persona.
Sabemos lo que esta tecnología vale para las ligas deportivas.
Genera miles de millones de ingresos al año,
pero ¿cuánto vale esta tecnología
para un profesor en el aula intentando mostrar a un abusón
cuán dañinas son su acciones
desde la perspectiva de la víctima?
¿Cuánto vale esta tecnología para un gay en Uganda o Rusia
intentando mostrarle al mundo cómo se vive siendo perseguido?
¿Cuánto vale también
para un Comandante Hadfield o un Neil deGrasse Tyson
intentando inspirar a una generación de niños
para que piensen más en el espacio y la ciencia
en vez de notas trimestrales y Kardashians?
Señoras y señores, la realidad aumentada se acerca.
Las preguntas que hacemos, las decisiones que tomamos
y los retos que enfrentamos, dependen, como siempre, de nosotros.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)